Lenny Martinez I'm a sophomore and air
Astro actually part of the saving Gora
Gora group our game is called saving
Gora Gora it's a game about well it has
to do with the topic color and our goal
was to sort of teach children how to
prevent cholera because our target
audience where Ghanian children ages 8
to 13 approximately and pretty much our
main goal was just to sort of educate
them in a fun way that wouldn't seem
like we're educating them
ok so our design brief was pretty
general it said can sit at the cholera
toolkit and that online you can find
online and try to create a game to sort
of teach kids about collar so they gave
us a target audience which is ghanian
children ages 8 to 13 and then we were
thinking of originally well it was an
idea that we had from based off animal
crossing where it's a bunch of different
mini-games so each minigame would
include a small lesson and then overall
like they would all come together to be
one large metal puzzle and solving that
metal puzzle the players would learn how
to I guess prevent color or counter
cholera and that was worth what led most
of our design process
the visual style came about what we had
a very well we had original visual style
was very different from what you guys
found the presentation um we had to
research we had done research on
children's but we had to sort of take a
look back and sort of redo everything
because it wasn't as like once we
compared it once we had a finished build
we compared it to some more research we
had to research on like sort of what
cartoons would better look like and we
found that our it was sort of very
different and very clashing so we did
some research more on Ghani and culture
and we sort of had to find make it sort
of fit better and so we went for a more
artsy would see cartoonish little very
little kid but it's still not too
childish for other people
I originally really was interested in
the class because one of the textbooks
was a design of everyday things and it's
the book I find really interesting i'm
like been trying to read it but it's
kind of hard with the curriculum or the
overall i mighta curriculum Bodom so I
really what came into the class thinking
that I really want to work on the design
aspect of things but as we started
working on projects the match went I'd
became a bit more interesting a bit more
something I started working a bit more
because it was more accessible for me
with my not so robust knowledge of
coding and but then later on for this
project particular I took the role of
the writer so I was in charge of writing
mostly Donna and I was also very
interesting so I feel like I gained a
lot more Skills than I thought I would
have
I think a really big part of the process
to start writing really early on the
writing we sort of left it off a bit
until we had the general minigames and
sort of used to writing to tie
everything back together but I think
would have been much more smoother
process or much more interesting process
we started the writing how he used the
writing to lead the design process but
it wasn't I mean it's what I better have
we start earlier but it wasn't too bad
of too much of a difference between the
work we have now in the work we had
before but aside from that I think it's
really important to start meet early
with like me early and like sort of come
to a consensus on what you want to do be
we had a lot of mini the reason a lot of
we had a lot of more mini games were to
begin with them when we ended and it was
good that we met early and sort of
decided what to cut and what to include
and that sort of helped us lead on like
work towards one common path
uh working with the client was very
interesting I we met him two three four
five maybe almost five times I think
Allah night we've met him a lot we've
met him a lot interacting with him was
interesting on the first time we met him
was where he did a lot of demonstrations
was sort of I guess showed us more what
we were supposed to be aiming for
because it was a very social interaction
very deep interaction and that I think
the goal of our games is to be a bit
more it's to be really deep also
appearing to be very just playful and he
also helped us um when we were going on
our tree works that he was suggesting
like maybe you should look at these you
should look more towards this type of
the culture this part of the culture of
this part and that was very nice there's
a sort of interacting
the class has been actually really fun
it's a lot of work and but it's a lot of
interesting workers once you see like
the game actually hadn't seen the final
like the builds we had until today I
think this actually is like really like
the diancie i had written the dialogues
separately so i was working so just
looking at the pic the art asset and it
was very nice to see everything come
together in one nice build of like
here's the game you helped make it's
wonderful